So if we think about our nuclear
chromosomes, and our mitochondrial chromosomes, that includes everything
that you see here in this picture. All of this is the total cellular genome, for
the total human genome. Now when I say the total human genome in this case, I'm
not referring to any individual human in particular.
I'm just referencing The constituent parts, or chromosomes,
that all play a role in making a
human. For example, we know that chromosome one, two,
three, four, five, six, seven, alright, all the way
down to the chromosome 22 and the sex chromosomes
and the mitochondrial chromosome is important in making a
human. Now for just a moment, don't count extra
copies of chromosomes. I want you to tell me
how many unique chromosomes are there in the total
cellular genome. Remember, I don't want you to count extra copies of
chromosomes. I want you to tell me how many unique chromosomes are there? It can
be a little tricky, so think about it before you answer. And I
want you to put your answer in number form in this text box here.